they've lost their minds over there it's
it's now a panel of
a bunch of liberals and one person who
wears the label conservative but agrees
with them on all the things that they
deem must be agreed with right so it's
like oh you can't stray on the vaccine
so that person has to sit there now and
basically
toe the line of the fake conservative
right they get to say they have
diversity on the panel they get to say
they have diversity of thought but that
person you know on these important
issues like a b and c
you can you either have to you know toe
the line we say or you have to make a
really feeble argument and let us win is
the bottom line
all right jedidiah you gave me a great
segue here because you mentioned joy
behar and the view and i talk often
about the view on this show we actually
show a warning before i play clips from
the view and it warns people that
whatever you're going to see is either
complete bs or insanity or something to
that effect i will say that many years
ago when i lived on the upper west i
lived two blocks away from joy behar i
would see her on the street she was not
insane back then i know it's hard for
people to believe but 10 years ago she
was not i loved her admired her she was
always very sweet to me her husband as
well
in my estimation she has lost her mind
whoopi has lost her mind
sonny i don't know what's going on there
i mean i i don't ever remember thinking
she was saying
anna these are crazy people that they
put at that table
jedediah you sat at that table for a
portion of your life and here you are
smiling in the free state of florida
explain that to people how does this
make sense yeah i mean and i didn't sit
there very long people may notice it was
about a year and a half i think i tested
for the show for a few months as i
recall i was still at fox i was actually
had one foot at fox as a contributor and
i was testing for that show at the same
time roger ailes at the time actually
gave me signed off on a like hey all
right she's probably not going to get
the job so let her just it'll be good or
go on over there and i was like i knew i
know i might be i was like great you
don't think i can get the job that only
helps me so i went over and i have to
say the show has changed drastically i
mean even in that show i mean that was
eight years ago it was a very different
show first of all it wasn't as
hard-wired for politics at the time i
was hosting with like candace cameron
and raven simone so there was a lot more
pop culture
but there was also it still had that
barbara walters feel to it where she
really valued different viewpoints she
defended that i don't know if you
remember that show a lot a while ago i
mean it was before i got there for sure
where bill o'reilly was on and whoopi
and just walked off that was in many
ways that was the beginning of the end
in some respects when the two of them
walked off right but that wasn't
tolerated by her she made it clear that
this would be called the view because
there were supposed to be different
views at the table when i got to the
show i have to say
for the most part i had a good dynamic
with the ladies behind the scenes
there was some concern i remember a
couple of times with a couple of
episodes for example the day that
hillary clinton was coming on which
oddly wound up being a couple of days
before i lost my job i don't know but
regardless who knows but the day before
um the day she came on i remember there
was a lot of panic because i was very
big on the email scandal and they were
worried that i was going to bring up
something that was uncomfortable like i
had asked hey can i show this document
that she signed that said that she knew
exactly what the sea and confidential
meant and she lied to everybody she lied
and they were like oh i don't know
there was a lot of like walking through
the hallways quickly and what's gonna do
that was well i actually didn't get to
an email question imagine that
i did ask her a question about being
tone deaf though so i felt like that was
gratifying for me but there was that
there was another instance i can't
recall i think maybe it was maxine
waters where i felt like tangible energy
of like uh oh you know
um the thing is though i noticed the
dress then i left the show i maintained
a good relationship with um you know the
the other hosts we had emailed here and
there
when i went back dave during this yeah
it was nuts what the hell happened to
these people what happened to them what
happened to the show
what's going on here i mean i got i went
through a full pre-interview they knew
exactly where i stood on the mandates i
was naive i was naive i felt like well
they know where i stand i'm gonna go on
they're gonna have a real conversation
with me i don't know why i thought that
but i thought well it would be
ridiculous i was a former co-host it
would just be so disrespectful to to do
anything but have a real conversation of
course i covet became an issue i
couldn't be on set even though i tested
covet negative in fact one time they i
was supposed to co-host several times i
was slotted to host i think four or five
times one time they came to my house
code tested me i tested negative i had
an exemption letter from my doctor that
said not only was i not a risk to people
at the time they were like she's not a
risk and here's her negative covet test
and this is medically advised against
for i submit all this stuff i test
negative and they say that's not good
enough you can't show up tomorrow i was
like and why'd you test me you're
testing the vaccinated people anyway it
made no sense uh but anyway ultimately
they tell me i can't be in studio i do
the show remotely and everybody saw how
that unfolded which was a shout fest i
was i say two things and i get shouted
down as misinformation all i was saying
was what was had already been
acknowledged by the cdc which is that
the vax can get and spread cove and so
the mandate didn't make any sense was
very clear like everyone should make
their own personal decision i didn't get
an apology i didn't get sonny went on
some
tangent on on instagram of post posting
all this stuff responding to me like
instead of responding to me in the show
because i didn't have an answer she went
on instagram it was i was like what is
going on you were at my wedding
girlfriend like what is going on here
so you know the commitment to the
ideology took precedence over
just mutual respect
over friendships over
it it's they've i'm sorry they've lost
their minds over there it's it's now a
panel of
a bunch of liberals and one person who
wears the label conservative but agrees
with them on all the things that they
deem must be agreed with right so it's
like oh you can't stray on the vaccine
so that person has to sit there now and
basically
toe the line of the fake conservative
right they get to say they have
diversity on the panel they get to say
they have diversity of thought but that
person you know on these important
issues like a b and c
you can you either have to you know toe
the line we say or you have to make a
really feeble argument and let us win is
the bottom line
so i i just don't and you know megan
wasn't like that
i don't know megan became very well but
i worked her a little bit of fox but
she's feisty you know she wasn't any she
wasn't taking any garbage there you see
how that went you know it's hard
it's not what they want it seems to be
that now
you know that's just not what they're
looking for diversity of thought is just
not it's not what they're interested in
it's sad
um we could have had a great discussion
that day about mandates i think the
audience would have loved to hear but
they knew that if i was allowed to talk
there would be people that agreed with
me and they can't have that they can't
have it for people that have not seen
your appearance on the view that you're
referring to when they went off on you
on this way we did cover it on the show
so we'll link to that down below so
people can catch the the clips of that
because it's really incredible and the
dismissive way they treat you and as you
said sunny was at your wedding like like
really crazy stuff you know it's funny
because when i play clips of the view
and it's usually i'm i'm obviously i'm
making fun of them and it's in some ways
it's low hanging fruit in a certain
degree but that thing for whatever
reason still is culturally relevant and
i think it's interesting that you
mentioned barbara walters because
obviously she was an icon of journalism
and she's not associated with it anymore
as far as i know or at least it's very
very behind the scenes
and obviously she's she's older now but
when she started that thing that the
very
purpose of the show was in the intro i
remember it 20 years ago we're going to
have these women of different walks of
life of different beliefs of different
religions of different skin goals that
we're talking about and now it's just
bash the hell out of whoever either a
fake conservative or a regular
conservative who can just take a beating
basically and megan couldn't take a
beating for that well she took it for
longer than you
and uh yeah it's exhausting and also i
mean the whole you say that and that is
true i think for a long time the barbara
walters that's all true but you always
had to wonder like why why is it forward
against one then yeah right like that
doesn't even make sense like you should
have on there you know a bernie sanders
style democrat they should have a
moderate democrat they should have an
indep somebody who's maybe you know
completely independent they have uh uh
you know a moderate republican and then
a harsh like a strong you want to really
grab you know you're talking about the
view it's like i don't need to see four
people pat each other on the back and
then one person get bullied that's not
enjoyable to me i think that it's it's a
household name it's a show that's been
around for a really long time i think
people say oh my my mom watched it you
know my my aunt watched it it was always
on in the house growing up it's iconic
but i have to say like it turned me off
i mean i was really
disgusted with how i was treated and i'm
also disgusted with the idea that like i
see i see who's going on there now and i
i see what's going on in the casting i
could just see it now i know they had a
problem with castings they everybody had
to be vaxxed and a lot of conservatives
were like i'm not playing that game yeah
i wasn't playing it obviously if i
couldn't go guest co-host a bunch of
times i wasn't going to be you know a
lot of people weren't playing that game
maybe that was a great way for them to
weed out the people they knew would be a
problem because it gets rid of you lisa
booth who's phenomenal good friend of
mine on fox news she refused to do the
guest gig because she or you know they
wanted her to get vacs to do it she said
no and then it's like okay that takes
out half the competition that
intellectually is going to own you
that's exactly right because those were
people who this was an issue where
people were saying you really had to
weed out people who were saying
i mean think about it though that's a
big show you know how many people would
have just got the vaccine just to do
that show no no because it's an
opportunity it is an opportunity it's an
exposure opportunity it's all that there
were people who were willing to say i
prioritize my health i prioritize my
well-being and i prioritize my integrity
more than doing your show and that was
just the bottom line i did the same
thing she did i said i was lined up to
do i think three guest spots plus during
my book launch week a couple of spots uh
back to back we were gonna do a whole
thing for my book and i was like you
know what
i i know my book i know this is gonna
hurt my book i know the book has my
son's face on the cover but i want to be
able to tell my kid more important than
that i sat on the view to promote the
book i want to be able to tell my kid
one day that i didn't sacrifice my
principles or what was right for me or
my health or my family for some show
that couldn't accept a medical exemption
for a vaccine that doesn't prevent
transmission because they're too you
know doubled down on their their woke
ideology and their you know dystopian
nightmare to allow for some diversity of
thought that's something i'll be proud
to tell my kid one day if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell